the gyro can experience in terms of
progress like what what has to happen
for there to be a shift in the the
biological age of people where you could
actually reverse it or we could actually
maintain the position they're at now for
extended periods of time
first of all let me answer that last
part so reversing aging is actually
going to be pretty much the result of
maintaining it there won't be a Justi
maintain it because that would mean that
you are repairing the damage of aging
just exactly at the same speed that the
damage is being laid down which is
ridiculous you know you know this if you
can do that you can obviously do it a
little bit faster that it's being laid
down so you don't really need to think
about the maintaining part however what
we need is we need to be able to repair
all of the types of damage and because
the human body is so very complicated
there are of course a lot of different
types of damage so it's a divide and
conquer strategy any of these types of
damage at the molecular level failure
level can perfectly well kill you more
or less on schedule however well we fix
all the others so since the beginning
sense research foundation my
organization has focused on the most
challenging the most difficult types of
damage because basically the easiest
ones are being worked on by other people
we have you see we set ourselves up as
an independent charity we're so we're
charity we're a public 501c3 which means
that if someone gives us money they get
a tax break but we're independent which
means that we do not rely on
peer-reviewed government grants or
anything like that we just roll for that
philanthropy the numbers advantage of
that is that we're not competing with a
lot of other people who have their own
ideas about what to do and in particular
the people who are deciding who wins
that competition or not you know in when
you prefer government grants it's
terrible you know you end up having to
basically emphasize really boring
low-hanging fruits just in order to have
a chance at getting funded because
people want to avoid funding things that
don't lead to high-profile publications
soon so you know really ambitious
high-risk high-reward stuff just doesn't
get done and
Phil we focused on that because other
people comped that makes sense and
that's very unfortunate that that
doesn't get done outside of what you're
trying yeah I mean of course this is a
recognized problem yeah and then I H for
example have tried to address it with
Awards with types of grants that are
specifically focused on more
cutting-edge visionary stuff but the
magnitude there is time it's real
tokenism you know it left the 1% of the
NIH budget what's frustrating to you
about the the state of understanding
repair and understanding the the ability
to fix things Wow
I'm not the kind of guy who gets
frustrated very much you know I'm always
a glass half-full kind of person so for
me what matters the most is the fact
that the understanding that this is what
aging isn't this is hard to deal with it
has improved so much over the years so I
started putting out the idea of that
this was the way to go after aging 20
years ago up until then the only game in
town really was we've got to make the
body run more cleanly and generate this
damage more slowly than it naturally
does and that's a very big conceptual
difference right so it's not surprising
that it took me maybe ten years to
really get the damage repair approach
taken properly seriously by my
colleagues in the scientific community
but about ten years ago it was taken
seriously and in fact over the past
decade people have been periodically
reinventing the idea and you know I
don't necessarily always get as much of
the credit as I probably ought to have
but I don't care about that the main
thing is I don't have to persuade anyone
anymore people get it that damage repair
is at least if not the way to go at
least a very promising way to go so
really what happens next is convincing
people outside of the community right
and there there's been enormous progress
as well so when you and I spoke last
five years ago really that was the end
of the story
I pretty much won the scientific
argument but still no one was really
listening and then over the past five
years the huge thing that's happened is
the private sector interests in this has
taken off so investors have been coming
along typically it's been led by the
angel investor
types their seed investors people who
are willing to do really high-risk
high-reward stuff but they understand
that we're getting close enough that
this is the next big thing that we will
actually have bonafide a genuine
rejuvenation medicine in the foreseeable
future how far seeable Wow you know some
of its already in clinical trials
like what kind stuff so for example the
stem cell therapy is now being used for
aspects of aging with a really clear
understanding of how they're going to
work Parkinson's disease is a great
example of this where stem cell therapy
is the right way to go and it's in
clinical trials something that's been in
the news a lot over the past couple of
years it's analytics which are drugs
that selectively kill what are called
senescence cells so these are cells that
hang out in the body in a bad state
where they're doing more harm good then
not only are they not doing what they're
supposed to they're also secreting nasty
stuff that damages their neighborhood
and so drugs have been developed that
are seemingly pretty good at getting rid
of those and they're in clinical trials
as well listen and so we don't work we
used to work on that area we basically
do no work on that area anymore hardly
any and we may end up doing that or a
couple years from now just because other
people are doing it and so our money is
better spent doing the stuff that's
still at an earlier stage and beyond
that you know we are able even for
things that are a couple of years behind
that so won't be in clinical trials for
another year or two um we've been able
even then to get investors interested so
that we can actually spin the projects
out and start up companies and focus on
the things that remain it's not just us
of course there's lots and lots of I
mean literally weigh over a hundred
other companies now that I work with
because they're not spin-out from my
foundation but they are you know doing
closely aligned work and so I'm I'm
literally spending probably a day a week
on average just making introductions
between you know in entrepreneur
founders and scientific founders of with
with great science and investors who
want to get involved
[Applause]